here is the truth you pass it down from  father son or father son grandson  me I've never been arrested no jack  shadow day time I've never been charged  can't you go home works you never have  to homework I never went to school  look you know look that's a legend  percent you did say we weren't living  with your dad for every chart Bob  potentials hey guys we can't be havin  your old man and there's a lot bit  enough rachelle community no troubles  and they want to keep it that way it's  all I want too got job for you tonight  all right  come make like this no more cop do it I  don't know all right Kel we'll get none  of you know  it's going to stop raining down on all  of us and they will break you on your  own you know that not if we stay tight  this is your phone Ola  I love you so much  get away from you call  it knew our boy I just try and look out  for my family  I'm your family  this is just the beginning